can we really rely on AI technology to
behave the way we wanted to can we
really control it and I think okay you
might have some questions for Ada for
that she could answer herself
okay here's the first question Ada if I
made down the barrel if I may Ada tell
me
should I be scared of you
hello there
thank you for speaking with me okay
okay she's being very polite my artwork
aims to provoke in the viewer
how and in what ways do humans want AI
to be developed and used in their
futures
through this exhibition I hope to open
audiences Minds to some of the different
Futures that may be arriving
we ultimately need to discuss this
uh are you going to wipe out Humanity
okay
many prominent voices in the world of AI
are suggesting some forms of AI should
be regulated
and I agree
for example
Jeff Hinton is one of the Pioneers in
artificial intelligence
and his work has helped shape the field
as we know it today
I think his opinions over AI are
important
and we should be cautious about the
future development of AI
who's going to win the Epsom Derby
as a humanoid
I cannot answer this as a human could
thank you for your thoughts and
questions
there you go okay
um Ada sharing her thoughts there but I
think the whole idea behind this is to
show how disruptive the technology of AI
can be for the creative Industries as
well and just oppose that question over
whether we really know where it's going